Hi, this is Matt Ganzac and this is the
OpenClaw token optimization guide. And
if you're not familiar with OpenClaw,
it's an AI personal assistant that you
can deploy locally. A couple of things
that I want to tell you. One, you
probably shouldn't do this if you're not
a developer or if you haven't deployed
apps locally before, developed any apps
before. So, I definitely don't recommend
it for you. Uh, number two is um be sure
to deploy it on a controlled
environment. So on a PC or Mac,
definitely Mac is better. Uh deploy it
on its own device. Like do not deploy
this on your own machine. It's going to
try to log in to your apps. It's going
to try to access things. It's going to
um one guy even said that it accesses
credit card. he went and asked it to
rebuild his brand and it went and bought
a $3,000 course, consumed the course in
order to help him to build his brand.
So, yeah, like it will literally go do
things for you and you need to be very
careful. So, I need to preface that
entire thing here. Uh, another preface
that I should add and a disclaimer here
is that I'm giving you the steps that I
took and if you're trying to follow
these exact same steps, there is a
chance that you'll possibly break your
open claw if you don't know what you're
doing. So, please don't try to do these
customization things uh if you don't
know what you're doing. So, it's not my
fault. I'm not doing the coding work.
I'm just giving you exactly what it is
that I did. And hopefully this will help
some people. I've been posting over on
Tik Tok and Instagram and I've been
helping a lot of people just in those
one minute videos. So, I want to make
something a little bit more
comprehensive to dive in a little bit
deeper uh to answer some of those
questions that I've been getting. So,
first off, uh OpenClaw again, it's an AI
that connects to um other platforms like
Claude, O Open AI, so forth. When I
first built my V1, I tried to use OpenAI
and it built the app like terribly and
it was uh it didn't do anything really.
So like I was just fighting it and it
was lying to me and it was really
frustrating. [snorts] So I terminated it
and did um uh V2 and I created V2 of my
app with Sonnet. And when I went through
um Sonnet's a little bit cheaper than
Opus and Haiku is cheaper than Sonnet.
So it's this hierarchy of um spend. But
that being said, it cost me about $3, a
little less than $3 to deploy and
configure the entire app for using
Sonnet. And it it it was definitely
worth it. Like it really gave me a good
foundation and a good architecture to
build on top of. But I noticed some
issues as I was running Sonnet. And
these are the steps that I took to
reduce my cost by 97%.
So it's a pretty massive shift in the
amount of tokens that were being used
and expensed. and I'll give you the um
exact reasoning and exactly how I found
it in the token audits that I do once a
day and how I fixed it step by step so
it's not you know real complex. All
right. Uh also below this video I'm
going to give you a link to this guide
so you can actually go through it and
copy and paste everything so you can
have a download to this. But let's run
through it. I'm not going to read every
single word on this page. You can read
it yourself. Um key thing is uh just
keying in down here before and after
like daily usage. Um uh this was daily
usage like just running one or two tasks
was like $2 to $3. So monthly would have
been you know $90 and and this is just
it almost just sitting idle. It was
still spending $2 to $3 a day just
sitting idle. And um now after
technically I'm at zero sitting idle and
I'll explain that in a moment. Uh but
you know you want this to be able to run
tests. So what sort of tasks do I have
it running? I have it finding
opportunities for us. Uh we run venture
companies. So I have it finding
opportunities and crafting outreach
messages. And I'm not letting it send
emails yet. I'm not letting it be fully
autonomous and do things like that. But
it's doing the research and um uh
getting valid email addresses. Uh I do
B2B business so a lot of our apps like
our hospital app um you know I can't run
ads to a hospital app and find the
specific you know VP of patient safety
at XYZ hospital. I'm not going to find
them through ads. Sure, I could do cold
outreach on LinkedIn, but you know, this
app is finding their LinkedIn profile,
but it's also finding their email
address, so I can send them an email and
kind of tell them about what it is that
we do and find a opportunity to work
together. So, B2B business, this is
phenomenal. Uh, you can do so much with
this. That's just one use case that you
can do.
Now, one of the things that I found was
wrong, and this is a core logic of the
architecture of OpenClaw is that it's
loading your entire history on every
message. It's loading all your context
files. It's loading and your context
files are a little bloated and the more
you know you put in your context files,
soul, user identity, etc., uh, the more
bloated it's going to be every single
time. So every heartbeat it's going to
um expense tokens. Every single time you
ask it to do something, it's going to
run your context files and so forth. So
I was wasting 2 to three million tokens
just on heartbeats. Like my heartbeat
was like running every 30 minutes and I
was expensing that many tokens every 30
minutes. I was like what's going on
here? Like I loaded up $25 to Anthropic
and uh I was on target like just sitting
idle to spend almost $20 in the day just
doing nothing. And that's definitely an
issue. Um and it it's not something
that's written into um you know the the
web platform and so forth. Uh so it's
not something that you could just go and
just do. You need to provision your app
in order to do these things. So this is
one thing that I did is I'm not loading
all the context files every single time
now. So that alone saved me like 80% of
my context overload just on that alone.
So that was a huge Here's my before and
after. So before it was about 50
kilobytes on context on startup and also
every single time I prompted it and also
every single time there was a heartbeat
like every single time it was just
bloating and getting bigger and bigger
and bigger as the memory was getting
bigger and bigger and bigger it like
that's just compiling the amount of
tokens. So if you've been using it for
weeks or months, you know, the context
might be much bigger for you and every
single time you take any sing any
action, your uh context file size could
be going from 50 to 75 to 100 and
beyond. And that's really compiling the
data usage for no reason. Like you're
literally doing nothing and you're
having to pay money for no reason. So
that's essential. The other thing is uh
a lot of people are saying that you can
only run one um AI model and it's wrong.
So I'm actually running three AI models
actually technically four because I made
another change just recently uh this
morning. But just going ahead and giving
you some understanding of this you'll be
able to go to your open claw uh your
config file. So this is your config
file. Inside of there you'll see agents
default model and then you'll see
whatever your primary model is. So if
you're setting it up initially on sonnet
this would be sonnet. You can set it up
this way to have multiple models. And I
also added a third one here for opus
that I have like 1% of my task going
through opus. So currently it's like 85%
is running through haiku somewhere
around there. uh 10% on sonnet and 5% on
uh or less on um opus. So the point of
saying that is you can segment tasks and
and put it into the memory and you can
segment tasks for this to say that task
is a brainless task and I don't need to
run opus for some brainless task uh you
know such as moving files around
organizing things like compiling CSVs uh
all into one or whatever it is that
you're doing as like a brainless data
entry task. You don't need to be using
Opus or Sonnet. You could use Haiku, but
I'm actually using um Olama, which is a
free LLM, and I'll explain that in a
second, but I'm using that to do my
brainless tasks and also my heartbeats
and so forth. getting ahead of myself,
but um point being you can have four
different models running at the same
time and then have your critical um and
uh different levels of the criticalness
of the tasks based upon what it needs to
be reasoning and thinking. You can
assign each model based upon your use
case, based upon what reasoning needs to
be included or what needs to be written
or so forth. and you can run things on
Haiku, which is like 10x 50x cheaper,
and be able to have the same output. So,
if you're just running Opus or you're
just running Sonnet or some other AI
model, you're probably burning tokens
for no reason because you could have one
of the cheaper models do the tokens for
you, right? So, you're adding routing
for it and you'll have to define what it
is that your business does and and what
it is that you need it to accomplish.
And then you assign which model based
upon which tasks you want it to do. And
if it hits a block, if there's like a a
block that will happen, it escalates to
the next highest model. If there's a
block there, it escal escalates to the
next highest model. So you can set it up
that maybe it it even starts with the
free, you know, uh, local LLM and then
maybe it goes to Haiku and then maybe it
goes to Sonnet and maybe it goes up
there to Opus as as a final and so
forth. So there are ways to do this. So
[snorts] before I was using Sonnet for
everything. So it was like a fraction of
a penny for a,000 tokens. Um, and I
brought it down considerably just by
having Haiku do like 80% of the lifting.
And, and now with that, I even have LLM
on the front. So, it can do probably 15%
of my front-end tasks. And it's probably
75% now if I were to say on Haiku, maybe
10% on Sonnet, and like 3 to 5% on Opus.
So, I can escalate things without
burning tokens. So, uh, you can put your
heartbeat on Olama. So, heartbeat is
when it it kind of pings the system to
let it know like, hey, everything's kind
of running. I do you have any active
tasks? If you don't have heartbeat
running, um, it it could just put itself
to sleep and not finish the task that is
at hand. But if you have heartbeat
running, it'll give it a little poke and
just say like, hey, what's going on
here? Um, you know, do you have any open
tasks? Do you need to move along on
these tasks? what what's going on. And
every single time it runs heartbeat, it
is sending context files and also um uh
searching u uh history, session history
as well. Um some people it's not
searching session history, but what I
found when I did my token audit is that
it is actually uploading my session
history. And we'll talk about session
history in a moment, but session history
is like if you're using Slack to
communicate with your bot or WhatsApp,
it's looking at everything that you've
ever said in Slack and it's compiling
that. When when I looked at my logs and
I I did a token audit, I had 111
kilobytes of session of just text that
was being sent. every single time I
prompted it again, it was putting it
into the context, putting it in, you
know, with the memory and uploading it
every single time. And I saw it, it was
in the logs. I was like, we don't need
to do that. So, you have to build a
command to kill your session and then
when you do a new prompt, it's not going
to be loading the context of every
single thing you've ever talked to it
about. kind of going off the rails here,
but um so you'll install this local LLM
and you can add it just like this. So
this is what mine looks like and you can
add the OAMA like this is the latest
version right now. If you're watching
this couple weeks or a couple months
from now, that version might be a little
bit different. So, I would just make
sure you have the latest version of it
and when you do run it, you can run it
here and then you can find the latest
version and make sure you install the
latest version, etc. So, with that being
said, now I can have Olama run my
heartbeats and uh purpose of that is I
don't want to expense tokens for
heartbeats. Like that's it sitting idle
and you are paying money. Like why would
you do that if you're on Opus and you
don't configure these things? You might
be spending $5 a day just to have it up
running and it's sitting idle not doing
anything. So why would you do that? So
why not set it up and configure it that
the heartbeat is just running locally
cuz it's it's brainless. Like there's
really nothing to it. It's like check
your memory and check your task and make
sure everything's okay. Um and then it
comes back system okay. um you know
heartbeat check okay or whatever words
are that it says but the point of that
is you don't need to be making API calls
for heartbeats period end of story this
should be a core integration into
openclaw and if it like hopefully like
somebody can commit this to it or maybe
I'll go and commit it to it but this
should be a core integration because
there is no reason that you should
expense uh API um uh tokens on
heartbeats period. Like I I can't I
can't think of any use case in why that
would be needed like that. There's no
reason for it because all it's doing is
just checking its local memory and
checking its local um uh task that it
has running. So why would you do that?
Another issue that I was running into
was rate limits. So, when you initially
sign up for Anthropic to have an API
key, it gives you something like 30,000
uh tokens per minute. And like I was
saying, and and this is where I found
the session history problem. And I
probably would have never found it if it
wasn't for the rate limit. So, thank you
for having a low rate limit that I could
see that. And it was pinging like a
million tokens and and uploading way too
much all at once for no reason. And what
I found was it was uh compressing all my
cont well it wasn't compressing it was
uncompressed all my context files and
then it was doing the call but it was
uploading my entire session history from
Slack every single time. So when I made
a command and I prompted it to make a
command and we came up with a command
name uh new session. So anytime I say
new session, dump all of your previous
session history but save it in your
memory so we can recall it at a later
time. So that's how my memory is
configured and I can dump my Slack
session. So it's not compiling every
single thing I've ever said in Slack
every single time I prompt it to send it
to the API in order to make a call. So
yeah, that was huge. And so that made a
huge difference with the rate limits.
And now I have built-in pacing. And uh
you can read how I did the built-in
pacing and so forth. And it's so
important so you're not hitting those
rate limits every single time. I was
getting uh 429 every single time I was
submitting. And um I figured out it was
Slack because I went to the web version
of it and I was doing the same exact
prompt in the web version, not in Slack.
and the calls were going through fine.
So I read the logs and read what was
being sent and looked at the tokens in a
token audit and then I went side by side
to say Slack is compiling every single
message I have ever sent Slack every
single time I prompted again. And I
haven't tested that on WhatsApp. If if
you have on WhatsApp like leave a
comment below and let me know. But I
would imagine that any um any messaging
platform that uh uh that does this and
allows you to communicate with it, it
probably does the same thing and it's
compressing it. It's taking your entire
session history and sending it uh to
expense AI tokens every single time uh
you use it. So, some other things I did
is I took my work plate uh my workspace
files and I compressed some of these and
I brought them down and then I told it
exactly what to do with my model
selection and the switching too and
switching back and forth. I put all the
rate limits in there and breaking that
all down as what it needs to do. Um, and
then I define some key metrics in here.
And you can put one of the metrics being
uh one of the metrics that you want to
accomplish is low token usage. So you
can literally tell it to optimize for
tokens. So now every single time I
prompt it, it tells me how many tokens
it's going to expense in order to
achieve the goal. Like go find me a,000
leads for this business and you know
find the best email address and find
their LinkedIn and find the decision
maker and yada yada yada yada whatever
and tell me how many tokens you're going
to expense. Now it's like you know it'll
use 60 tokens or 60 cents on that uh in
order to achieve that. I'm like okay
great do it. Then at the end uh it tells
me how many tokens it actually used and
uh I'm able to say like oh well we were
close or you know what was wrong what
was the block what was the problem and
then we can work through that and and
work through it but in the um you know
success metrics that is one thing I
added in there run efficiently like run
efficiently so I'm not expensing tokens
for you know no reason. I've had some
people messaging me um uh and you can
verify your entire setup and go through
these steps and you have a little uh
checklist here. I had some people
messaging me saying like, "I went to bed
and I woke up in the morning and it
burned $500." Like that's another thing
is don't like until you really get this
thing dialed in, don't allow for
Anthropic to automatically bill you.
Like just add a couple of dollars on
there and then be like really mindful of
how that's being spent. So I have on my
screen if you were looking at my screen
of my agent. This is not my agent. This
is my laptop. Uh but on my agent, I keep
the um the dashboard for the tokens up
and then each time that you know I run a
test um I I take a screenshot of the
tokens and I give it back to the
OpenClaw bot and I say you know uh uh
compare what you think the token usage
was and what you thought the cost was to
the actual cost and the actual token
usage. So, I give it a couple of
screenshots from the dashboard and then
it's like, "Okay, great." You know, I'm
I'm calibrating now to make sure that
it's more accurate. I had to do that
like three times and once I did it three
times, it got to the point that it was
like 99% accurate to um figure out what
the cost would be. Another thing really
important to do, and I didn't add it in
here, but I probably will, is caching.
So you the cache API cost is way lower
than anything else. So, I ran a task and
it was like 95% of the task was on uh
cached um uh tokens and so forth. And I
ran this like massive task overnight and
it was probably like 6 hours of just um
doing research and looking things up and
writing emails for me and writing
followup and you know putting it all
into the right folders and organizing
everything and and doing all that for
me. And at the end it was like that cost
you $6. I'm like that is insane because
you know we pay as a venture studio like
we pay people to go and do research for
us, do data entry and go find decision
makers. So, we pay people to do that and
it cost us tens of thousands of dollars
and the performance of what it is that
they do versus what uh OpenClaw did
overnight for me in one day overnight is
basically what I would pay that company
a month to do research on. And it did it
overnight and it was like $6. I'm like,
this is absolutely insane. So, you know,
I can do my work and work, you know,
work through my day and have it help me
out and and help me through things, but
at the end of the day, I can say, "Hey,
go find me some new um, you know, go
find me a new hit list for XYZ." And
when I wake up in the morning, it'll
have a hit list all organized and all
refined, everything compiled in a master
list, etc. So, it's incredible. So when
I set this up and the way that mine's
set up is we spin up these sub agents in
order to you know do the the crawling
work and I'm using uh Brave search API
and then I'm using like hunter.io to go
and find their real email addresses both
APIs and what it's doing is it's
spinning up these sub aents. It spinned
up like spun up like 14 sub aents for me
and it did all the work based upon this
one was doing this and then Sonnet was
doing the research and writing the thing
and Haiku's going out there and running
it and then on the back LLM the uh Olama
is organizing all the files. So they're
feeding the data in and then the sub
agent for OAMA it was just organizing
files and putting things together and
making sure the headers and the CSVs
look good and everything. So I had three
different agents running. I didn't have
Opus running at all in the task last
night. I had um I I had haiku going out
there and finding the information like
it was reading blogs and you know I was
looking for distressed businesses and
and so forth. So it was reading blogs,
it was reading like all these insights
and you know doing all this research and
everything and then it was finding one
pushing it over to Sonnet. Sonnet was
writing my emails and my cold outreach
and what I need to do for today to reach
out to them and structuring all the
followup and all of that of what it
needs to do. And then the Lama uh on the
LLM was organizing the files and getting
my file structure put together and
making sure everything was clean. So
when I wake up in the morning, I can
just do the task and I'm doing the
outreach. I'm not letting this machine
do outreach right now. Maybe in the
future I will, but today no. So, like
then I can set up my outreach and and
set up, you know, getting demo calls
booked and and getting situations going
on. And it ran for $6. It ran all night,
six hours for $6. So, it's like a dollar
like an hour. It's [laughter] like just
put your head around that. If I had it
running 24 hours a day, um it would be
about a dollar an hour. And no one is
working for a dollar an hour this
efficiently, having 14 sub aents running
and doing things all at the same time
and working interchangeably.
That's what is insane about this
platform. But if you know some people
are just run Opus. If you're literally
just running Opus, that task would have
been like $150 that happened last night
and it cost me $1, right, for an hour,
right? So, that is what's insane about
this, but you need to be mindful of the
token optimization and that's why I put
this thing together. If you have any
specific questions, you can mention them
in the comments. I'll jump in and try to
help you guys out along the way. But, I
want you guys to reduce your token cost
because you're not going to run this
thing and it's not going to be
efficient. You're not going to be happy
with it if you're expensing 50 or even
what the one guy said $500 in tokens
overnight. uh and it it's doing a little
bit but really not crushing it for you.
Right? So hopefully this was helpful. Um
leave a comment below if you have any
questions and you can link below to this
document and follow the steps and get
yours optimized to have those multiple
sub aents and then run the different
tasks based upon um you know the
reasoning that you need. Haiku is great
for like most things. Haiku can do most
things. um you know, sonnet for writing,
uh doing some coding, opus for like the
most complex and so forth, but install
the lama, install the local LLM to do
the basic things, heartbeat and
everything, and you're going to reduce
your AI cost significantly by doing
this. So, thank you guys so much. See
you on the next video.